I'd like to ask a little bit about how
you got into this idea of the kind of
person who could do this kind of mission
and why that became kind of an
organizing principle for the story so we
have the ISS right and we have the Space
Shuttle missions that's about 200 miles
up and in the ISS your field division is
still essentially mostly at planet Earth
huge difference apparently
psychologically when you're standing on
the moon's surface and you see the earth
as a separate fairly small blue dog in
fact we made it a little larger than it
should be in the movie when Donald
Sutherland points it out because it was
too small really to make any impact so
sorry sorry but what's interesting is if
you look at what happened to the 12 guys
who walked on the moon Neil Armstrong
basically retreated to his farm in
Lebanon Ohio you never heard from him
again
Buzz Aldrin very publicly dealt with
real problems of depression and abuse
substance abuse Charlie Duke became a
born-again Christian minister Edgar
Mitchell started talking about aliens
and magic men who would fix his pancreas
they something happened and what I we
had felt we had come across a piece I
mean I might want to say 2011 where it
was talking about four people for a Mars
mission which they're hoping is 2033
four people who would be in an area for
two years that's maybe half the size of
this stage here and they were looking
for people who had kind of what we might
call schizoid personality disorder
because it was sort of on the spectrum
you know because quote-unquote normal
people it's more difficult to be in a
space like that for that length of time
they wanted to find people who were very
much okay by being by themselves but
what they found is testing all of this
psychological profile testing they call
it the most horrible torture is solitary
confinement some form of solitary
confinement
you don't have the option to leave and
kind of like prisons yes like prisons
and and you know there's actually some
debate I think it was Justice Breyer
although I could be wrong about this
who's recently sort of come out and said
that solitary confinement is cruel and
unusual punishment try and make it
unconstitutional but if you think about
it some guy or woman or who we were
going to Neptune for that length length
of time that's prime you know that's
right you're ready for mental breakdown
I mean there's no doubt about it
so we were just trying to say we really
were not built to be there it's not it's
not hospitable and it's the inevitable
outcome is that kind of breakdown I
think Ethan when you're starting to
write at what point you come up with
this idea of the psychological
evaluation that you have this moment in
the story where you actually get to hear
the characters talk about how they're
feeling and what they're feeling that
that becomes kind of touchstone
throughout the film this check-in about
what kind of person this is and how he's
dealing with the situation he's into
that was pretty early because we realize
he'd be alone a lot of the time and
would have to check in with his feelings
and the only way we could really know it
would be through the psychological
evaluation this was before we I think
wrote any voice over and cited -
voiceover so voice over obviously is the
other technique for that but didn't we
we talked about but we talked about vo
as the extension of the psych evals
right that was the first sort of
iteration of them which was like the
psychological profile thing that you
just asked about that's they were doing
it to the mercury astronauts
you know not to a computer obviously but
doing heavy attempts to sort of figure
out what their profile was if it came
across that I don't remember where but
it seems like you remember more than I
do I don't know and it's obviously
intentional and watching the film the
idea of that as somebody's trying to
look inward
he is looking outward that that you are
having this inner personal journey set
against this huge backdrop obviously you
realize that on some obvious level but
at what point you try to have those two
ideas plain
off each other it's good question
well the idea that we talked about that
makes it interesting is the further away
he goes from Earth is the enables them
to get into touch with what he should
have been in touch with on the earth
only by leaving everything it does he
see it for the first time really yeah
the idea was the contrast of it you know
what I mean that in some sense as far
out as you can go the edge of the solar
system is the way that you can kind of I
mean you only miss you only miss
something when you don't have it you
know that was the idea it's almost like
the converse of the profile of the
astronaut who might have gone to space
and then something broken them and come
back he almost was broken already and it
was the opposite thing that happened to
him he the same trait that makes
somebody willing to leave Earth for
years and years that shows a great deal
of courage and but it also makes show a
big flaw or a big pain that needs to be
reconciled I want to ask you about the
smaller things too and about editorial
because there are scenes like I'm
thinking about the general scene and the
Lima project conversation about editing
dialogue as opposed to action and
whether or not in some ways that might
be more time-consuming in terms of
figuring out what the edits going to be
and if you have as many spirited
conversations about how you're cutting
dialogue as opposed to cutting action
you know I honestly have to say that
dialogue scenes drama scenes are more
challenging I find action scenes to be
fun they are challenging and in and of
themselves but they they seem to come
together you know if it's working or not
working dialogue scenes are so much in
nuance and subtext and so you mentioned
the general scene I think you know that
that was largely an expository scene
that sets our hero off on his journey
and and that I I think we just worked
from you know the first day of
post-production to the last day but you
know that that's a really important
scene to talk about because I think
I think one of the things where the
accomplishments of James's film I think
is that it is that it conforms to some
familiar tropes but it's not it's not
iterative I think of them so I mean in
that scene it's a disaster movie
situation right someone's threatening
the world someone's got to do something
about it it's this guy but it doesn't
present in that form it presents in some
other form there are other things going
on there's a paranoid aura to it I think
it was you know brilliantly constructed
and I think that's I think that's an
example of the fine kind of alchemy that
this film was able to achieve where it
where it has scale it has scope but it
doesn't it doesn't feel like it's one of
those it feels like it's own film and I
think I think it was brilliantly handled
by um by James and his team Alan what
were the initial conversations about
where your expertise was going to guide
some of the decisions that James was
gonna make with the camera and the
things that he wanted to represent given
that he wanted to shoot as much
practically as possible in a movie that
inevitably had a lot of visual effects
actually I think the first conversation
was he went to shoot on 16 millimeter is
that true it was yeah it's 100% true I'm
owning up to it what do you mean I will
thought I thought it would look great
and then Alan went yeah that's a
ridiculous idea all right take it away
I'll go ahead humiliate me I'm fine so
you know we settled on 35 so you know
it's okay but it you know everything
that James wants to do we always try and
strive for shooting some sort of
elements so that it's not a full digital
shot and we try and reserve those for
the ones we actually have to do it
always lends a sense of realism to the
shots and I think that the more you do
blow with that and the more elements you
composite together the better at the
final result will be you try to do as
much as practically as you can and you
try to add right we definitely did this
add some kind of analogue idea to every
shot even if it's digitally you had a
flare of some kind something to trick
the eye because even when you even
sometimes you see high-res photographs
from the ISS or something to kind of
look fake because they're too perfect
they're too perfect
exactly and we don't understand that
kind of perfection at least I don't well
I think also I mean I think what you
guys were able to achieve is keep this
film very earthbound you know we're it
never it never kind of falls into that
like highly synthetic you know soup most
what's the word I mean we're we're
you're watching something that isn't
connected to our reality that feels like
it's an Avengers movie maybe no I'm
sorry I would never know I think I think
um I just think there is a grammar in
science fiction that tends to privilege
futurism things that are things that are
not maybe that don't feel mundane and I
think there's a there's a tremendous
sense of the mundane and the ordinary
throughout the visual effects process
which I think accounts for why there's a
depth of feeling to the film this is a
movie that is produced by you and didi
and a certain actor named Brad Pitt and
I'm curious about how Brad came onto the
project and what kind of dynamic or
challenge that presents when the actor
is also the producer and how you guys
talk about that what's right for the
company what's right for Brad and when
are they the same thing
well um Brad and James have known each
other for many years have always talked
about working together there was a you
know discussion about lost city of Z
Brad then saw lost city of Z and he and
James talked about this next project
which you know I think really touched
Brad in a deep way as an artist and as a
as an actor and um and I'm grateful that
our company was invited to produce it
alongside um a bunch of other great
producers Anthony Kat agus who couldn't
be here tonight but has produced a bunch
of James's other films as well as other
films with us and actually um a
Brazilian company that under wrote some
of the original development but
maintained an involvement Artie features
and so as far as you know Brad's
involvement I mean I think you can tell
from the film that it's it feels very
it feels like a very personal film it's
a very courageous I think performance
and a very very kind of understated and
yet also very bold and and and daring
performance this this sort of producing
acting comp you know conflict or not or
managing all that I think you know it's
something that our company is done for a
while I I give I think Brad has an
inherently enormous respect for
filmmakers and and respecting their
vision and sees himself in that context
in just like a core way I think that you
know in this film you know there is I
think a harmony of actor and producer
it's hard to really describe why that
would be or how that is I guess it's not
always that way but I feel that um you
know I think that I think that you can
tell that you know it's it will it was
it was him in functioning in those
capacities and yet it's still inside of
and and driven by this this you know
highly original science-fiction vision
which um you know we're used to seeing
aliens either as you know kind of mortal
enemies that are gonna destroy everybody
or or some kind of benevolent beings
that are gonna teach you how to be and I
think James found this this vision that
he projected in which you know we we do
something else and I think that's
something that's really really difficult
to pull off and and he did Alan John
Jeremy Ethan James thanks for bringing
us your film and for talking about